[Musique]
vous êtes nombreux à avoir reçu de faux
texto de desjardins
sébastien fradette de québec en a reçu
un qui dit ceci une erreur comptable a
été commise dans votre compte accéder et
a été corrigé comme cet intrigant on est
porté à cliquer pour voir karine coutu
de cookshire eaton a reçu elle une
variante qui dit ceci votre banque en
ligne desjardins a été suspendu en
raison de vérifications de sécurité
si vous êtes bon en français vous avez
un avantage parce que vous voyez tout de
suite que desjardins n'enverrait jamais
un texto écrit comme ça
desjardins n'utilise pas le mot banques
puisque ce sont des caisses les
fraudeurs ne sont pas très bons dans les
petits détails
dans les deux cas les liens mènent une
fausse page du site web ou de
l'application mobile reste identique à
celle que vous voyez qui vous demandent
votre identifiant et votre mot de passe
je vous rappelle que si desjardins vous
envoie un texto ou un courriel il ne
contiendra pas de lien cliquable
il ne vous demandera jamais de
renseignements personnels alors voilà ci
avoue aussi on attendait passer un sapin
je vous invite à nous le signaler
[Musique]